what's up everyone I'm Walter beneath
yak and this is top 5 with his newest
alien covenant just days away director
Ridley Scott's work is once again in the
spotlight last week we commended this
celebrated Acura on his long career but
this week we take a look at a few of his
films that just don't measure up before
we get started I wanted to tell you guys
I just launched a Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome Walter B make
sure you stop by and give it a like also
over on my personal channel youtube.com
slash awesome Walter a QA with the one
and only Zack Snyder just went up go
ahead and check it out while Scott is
one of the greatest living directors
even he is an immune to a misstep now on
them being responsible for some very
important films to cinema history is a
large burden to bear your work is always
going to be compared to that of your
greatest potential what may be
acceptable in another directors
filmography can be seen as a letdown for
someone of such great talent Ridley
Scott is one of those great talents in
his 40-year career he directed dozens of
projects and some of those projects have
become legendary make no mistake about
even when Scott makes a subpar film it's
still made well care and effort can be
seen in every frame however that doesn't
change the fact that a few of his films
aren't exactly on the level of alien or
gladiators these are my top 5 worst
Ridley Scott movies number 5 Hannibal
this one had a lot to live up to with
1991 Silence of the Lambs as its
predecessor unfortunately it didn't meet
those high expectations based on the
book and taking place ten years after
the events of the original film dr.
Hannibal Lecter is at large in Europe
one of Lecter's original victims Mason
Verger survived his attack but was left
horribly disfigured he had to plan for
revenge on his would-be killer but needs
someone to draw him out someone who is
very familiar with the deranged doctor
FBI special agent Clarice Starling now
this film isn't directed poorly none of
these really are it's the final product
and amount of fan of and Hannibal does
fit that description
while Silence of the Lambs was subtle
and clever in its horrific nature
Hannibal is very blunt and crass all the
nuance is gone are you paying attention
to me ex Special Agent stalling most of
the performances are silent in this
Anthony Hopkins brings it as Hannibal
and is still intimidating however I
think a big problem is the chemistry
with Hopkins and Julianne Moore this
isn't her fault but I feel like Moore is
sometimes trying to do a Jodie Foster
impression and it comes off sort of
cheap the energy Foster and Hopkins
shared in the first film just could not
be duplicated they complemented each
other perfectly
that is sorely lacking in this sequel
Ray Liotta feels a bit out of place here
and Gary Oldman is hamming it up as
Verger in the best way of course I have
immunity from the US Attorney's and I
had an immunity from the Risen Jesus and
nobody thinks there is in the end it
just couldn't match what Silence of the
Lambs did and while it was obviously
tried here something about the film left
a really bad taste in my mouth after all
as your mother
turns you out my mother suddenly told me
it is important jobs just to say I was
too trying to things
maybe that's why number 4 Prometheus
this film was kind of a prequel to alien
and that was the biggest thing going
against it for me clues to mankind's
origins lead an array of
corporate-sponsored space foragers to a
planet that may contain the answers
they're looking for upon arriving they
even discover ruins that might verify
their theories as they dig deeper into
what they found terror begins to spread
an unimaginable horror poisons their
once
earnest quest I didn't like this film
when I saw it in theaters and was hoping
my mind would change after seeing it
again a few years later it did right
from the start of Prometheus I was just
never drawn in the elements were all
there
Scott's amazing visuals and a seemingly
interesting mystery surrounding the
genesis of humanity but I could never
and still can't get into this movie one
of the reasons may be a lack of
interesting characters I never really
connected with anyone while Elizabeth
Shaw was sympathetic enough she wasn't
compelling like Ripley was an alien
there was just no anchor it's Christmas
captain and I would open my presents I
don't really have anything to preview in
the gigantic young body a ring up big
things have small beginnings but I'm
fairly certain your engineers are
nothing but scribblings of savages
living in dirty little caves
everyone else is a jerk greedy and evil
robot or whatever guy Pierce was
supposed to be seriously though I hated
that makeup I'm assuming they casted
Pierce because they were going to do
more with a younger version of his
character in future movies but I'm
pretty sure everything has changed since
then instead of following Elizabeth into
a sequel like we were supposed to a new
course was set and now we've arrived at
alien covenant five years later maybe
some questions will be answered in this
new film lord knows we just got more
questions in this prequel was that by
design I'm sure but I get the feeling a
lot of those questions won't ever have a
proper payoff now the only scene that
got me hooked for a few minutes was
Elizabeth in the med pod that was great
on a few levels we also get an almost
xenomorph at the end to remind us this
was an alien film
Prometheus aimed high and while it's
spectacular look at it never stuck with
me anything like Scott's first attempt
in this universe hoping for better
things with covenants besides they
didn't even put Bob in the box number
three Black Rain Michael Douglas and
Andy Garcia starred in this 1989 action
thriller it's probably the most dated
film on this list in New York policeman
Nick and Charlie witness a murder and
capture the killer it turns out he is a
member of the Japanese Yakuza and the
New York cops must have scored him back
to the Land of the Rising Sun however
once arriving they unknowingly hand him
off to his fellow mobsters and the
killer is on the loose in his country of
origin now Nick and Charlie must track
him down in an unfamiliar land with a
local police force who are less than
willing to help this is pretty bad but
kind of in a good bad way sometimes
Michael Douglas's character whines and
complains his whole way through this
movie he's angry all the time to the
point where it becomes humor
[Applause]
Friday
love the fight scenes in the film
classic stuff
[Music]
major spoilers here spoilers okay Andy
Garcia dies in this movie in the most
ridiculous way possible I think it's
supposed to be horrifying but the whole
scene leading up to it and the actual
execution just comes off as out of
nowhere and hits erekle to me have a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
the ATR and a big character towards the
end of this film is kung fu movie bad or
good you be the judge you should be
somewhere over the Pacific now Conklin
you have any idea who I am yeah I know
you are the biggest sin against this
movie is that it ends on the absolute
perfect point for a freeze-frame and
doesn't do it
[Music]
have lived my life my ways for tonight
and for today is the strongest harshness
yeah we're fixing that
[Music]
have lived my life Maui for tonight and
fall today ultimately this had a few
good moments but black rain is just
pretty lame considering what we know
scott is capable have lived my life Maui
number two 1492
conquest of paradise this was the most
difficult movie for me to get through in
Scotts whole filmography the famous
story of Explorer Christopher Columbus
is told in this continent spanning epic
with Queen Isabella the first funding
his journey Columbus sets out to sea and
lands in what they call San Salvador he
and his crew interact with the natives
and later he's ordered to start billing
a town their pensions begin to rise
among his men and the peaceful new world
Columbus wanted seems as far from him as
the voyage he traveled let's just set
aside the likely many many historical
inaccuracies about this film and discuss
it as just that it sucks I really really
had a difficult time sitting down and
watching this entire thing of course we
know the visuals will be gorgeous in
every Ridley Scott film and this is no
exception make no mistake there is some
breathtaking shots in this and I admire
what they must have had to go through to
make this look as good as it did but
that's where my admiration ends the
movie is par for the course in terms of
length for a Scott film but for whatever
reason it feels like it goes on forever
part of that may have to do with its
leaf Girard bit saw you plays Columbus
as a goofy goat
[Music]
the natives are to be converted to a
wave then it will be by persuasion and
not by force
hey at least we hear this name a few
times a medical a speech a medical this
Amerigo Vespucci
love that damn name the man America is
named after has a grand and lonely
Italian boredom sets in quickly here if
you want to check it out I'd say have it
on mute while doing something else and
occasionally glance at the pretty
pictures Jia depower do Amerigo Vespucci
yeah her dipper
be America love this yes and the number
one worst Ridley Scott movie is the
counselor my mind had bought this movie
out so much that I didn't even realize I
had seen it before until 15 minutes into
re watching it the counselor is a high
level cartel lawyer who gets involved in
an ill-advised drug deal the counselors
friend Rainer has a girlfriend who sets
them up without their knowledge and upon
learning he's not in the good graces of
some bad people the counselor tries to
go off the grid quick with his recent
fiancee Laura however things do not go
smoothly for him or anyone else who was
involved with this botched drug trade
the counselor is dull cruel pretentious
and poorly written the actors in this
are all good actors but the material
makes them come off really bad the
themes are pushed so hard in this one
that it feels like you're being preached
to for half the movies man and I try to
do for all the women too of course but
their illusion is that they can fix them
women don't want to fix anything the
other one I've entertained the truth of
all women is you can do anything to them
except boredom
the only thing I barely remembered from
this film was the bizarre story about
how Cameron Diaz had sex with the
windshield of a car yeah
artistic hallucinatory you see feeling
very changes Michael Fassbender is a
great actor he really is and the
counselor he's forced into weird
conversation
reactions are unconventional do you love
your wife so much so completely that you
would exchange places with her upon the
wheel yes tell you that time I think
I'll take a small nap
hey Natalie Dormer and John Leguizamo
are in this movie for a minute which I
really appreciated
so the counselor has that going for it
Cameron Diaz is supposed to be the
manipulative mastermind in this thing by
the way the script has reviewed complete
nonsense towards the end but mercifully
end this strange experiment stunter has
grace is our faintness of heart that is
driven us to the edge of ruin nothing is
crueler than a coward and the slaughter
to come is probably beyond our imagining
once again this is a subjective list
even more so than with the acting
performance top fives I do it's okay to
like these movies except for the Templar
Ridley Scott isn't quite uncuttable but
all his films are made with quality and
care it's something I really respect
about him and why I like a lot of his
movie so much I want to hear what you
guys think what is your least favorite
Ridley Scott movie leave a comment and
let me know for more content like the
Zack Snyder Q&A subscribe to my personal
channel youtube.com slash awesome Walter
like my new Facebook page facebook.com
slash awesome Walter B and follow me on
Twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future come
back next week true believers for our
brand new episodes of top 5
you
[Music]